pour le groupe l'est républicain merci
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la justice que je ne vois
pas je dire d'abord que pour aller
manifester place vendôme il va falloir
maintenant prendre son tour longtemps à
l'avant ce temps l'ensemble des
professions judiciaires et juridiques
est exaspéré hier c'était les policiers
jeudi ce sont les gardiens de prison et
aujourd'hui c'est l'ensemble des avocats
de france qui est en grève
ceci a raison de la réforme nocturne et
sans concertation du financement de
l'aide juridictionnelle
vous avez augmenté le budget vous avez
relevé le plafond vous avez étendu le
périmètre de ses missions mais comme
vous n'avez pas les moyens de vos
largesses voulait fait de pino financé
par d'autres dont les avocats d'une part
en diminuant certaines rémunérations
déjà souvent payés au prix du baby
sitting et d'autre part en prélevant un
impôt sur les cartes pas en 2016 et en
2010 16 2017 et en annonçant après
l'idée d'une taxe sur les cabinets
l'écart passe ont déjà très contrainte
elle finance seul l'entière gestion de
l'aide juridictionnelle qui concerne 1
millions de justiciables de tous les ans
et elle finance les écoles du barreau
elles ne pourront pas supporter cette
ponction sans compromettre l'accès au
droit
mais question sont les suivantes
premièrement est ce que vous confirmez
que 35 millions d'euros n'ont pas été
dépensés en 2014 sur le budget de l'aide
juridictionnelle
deuxièmement estimez-vous pertinent de
bloquer le fonctionnement de la justice
de prendre le risque d'avoir à récupérer
la gestion de l'aide juridictionnelle
qui était jusqu'ici assuré tout en
refusant de recevoir les professionnels
même si j'entends dire que la garde des
sceaux aurait changé d'avis sur ce sujet
nous verrons cela demain enfin
envisagez-vous d'écouter les
propositions qui vous ont été faites et
d'abandonner cette réforme injuste et de
ne pas frapper les avocats comme ce fut
le cas à lille lorsqu'ils manifestent
merci monsieur au lion la parole est à m
le secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement m
marie le guen merci monsieur le
président monsieur le député christiane
taubira garde des sceaux et devant le
sénat en train évidemment de faire son
travail de relations avec le parlement
depuis quinze ans vous le savez mieux
que quiconque que monsieur le député
houillon s'accumulent des rapports des
propositions parce que aujourd'hui le
système d'aidé juridictionnelle
s'essouffler ci n'ait rien fait rien
n'est fait il risque même l'agonie donc
nous avons toujours affirmé l'ambition
de le réformer pour rendre ce système
durables plus justes mieux rémunérateurs
pour les avocats qui font de l'aide
juridictionnelle ce qui n'est pas la
majorité d'entre eux ils assurent une
véritable mission d'intérêt général
l'état dans le contexte budgétaire que
vous connaissez à lui-même fait des
efforts considérables 345 millions
d'euros en 2014 405 millions l'année
prochaine et il y a eu aussi une
concertation qui a été menée de façon
longue
ce progrès les progrès que nous mettons
en place pour les justiciables d'abord
ses cent mille justiciables
supplémentaires qui auront le droit
d'être pris en charge mais aussi les
avocats seront mieux rémunérés aussi
bien l'acte de référence qui peut à
passée de 22,5 à 24,2 euros ainsi que
avec des aides particulières pour les
barreaux de dans les zones rurales
souvent de longs déplacements qui seront
yara 25 millions d'euros qui seront
affectés à cette aide juridictionnelle
prioritaire est donc aujourd'hui il est
proposé effectivement une participation
des carpates qui comme vous le savez ce
sont des caisses géré par les avocats où
transite le fond des justiciables et de
l'état sur les produits financiers
générés par le placement de ces fonds
voilà cette participation d'ailleurs
limitée à deux ans des discussions
doivent se poursuivre le gouvernement
recevra demain les trois organisations
représentatives des avocats mais soyez
positif fait que cette réforme avance le
député plutôt que d'être toujours dans
l'opposition
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame françoise